indeed richard this tournament
if you seem like you have a sort of
guarded face about how this all went
tell me your thoughts
uh yeah i basically learned the lesson
that you know ambition is the enemy of
success
i even you know um my loss was clearly
uh you know due to overambition and also
like my yesterday and today's play
uh i i'm very let's say displeased or
unsatisfied with the quality of my play
yesterday also he was playing very solid
and i was trying to take chances
and okay i ended up you know giving him
all the chances he could hope for
and today basically i you know got a
very nice position and i guess due to
tiredness and also the class of my
opponent he just you know
kind of tricked me you know
like not a little bit here like a lot
around the time travel and i
think it's kind of a miracle that my
position was still you know uh
holdable because i had to i had this
like rookie one was like you know really
really lucky uh move that nothing was
working for him and of course
i mean i kind of saw the idea but of
course i couldn't foresee that you know
nothing will work in the rook and game
as well i was just you know
holding on to for my life yeah did you
miss rook d4 no no i saw i mean i you
know i actually played this rook at 4
was i think just very uh stupid i missed
the screen e6 and after 26 i saw this
[ __ ] idea i mean i
saw rook
and the rook and game i'm catching the
pawn but it easily could have been that
you know he enters the rook and game i
am catching the palm but the rook and
games lost for me right so uh that was a
bit lucky but um
yeah
around move i don't know 40 usually i i
i made quite a few mistakes in this
tournament so yeah
ah the critical 40th move you ended up
in clear fifth
right outside
the the top four players
first place and then second through
fourth
do you feel like that's the fair result
for how you play this tournament i don't
know what's fair actually for anyone
really i mean fifty percent is you know
i guess uh
with you know not capitalizing on my
chances but giving some chances as well
i guess it's balanced
um
you know yeah it's just very strange
that my game was the longest one right
because basically speaking i think
i was the only player where you know um
even if i had won the game it wouldn't
have changed much in the standings
so
yeah but i think you know
i mean i could have done better it could
have done worse i think it's okay
all right well we admire your fighting
spirit and uh we'll know you'll bounce
back before you go tell us your next
events uh coming up uh yeah i'm going to
be playing in uh in norway uh i think it
starts really soon i think september 7th
or something like that
um
yeah after that i'm not quite not sure
yet if i will be playing this grand
space or or not or something similar
we'll see
all right well good luck in norway in
the rest of your tournament thanks
thanks for joining us